all right
wow
that's congratulations uh I am a
grandfather that's exciting is it more
fun with the grandkids because you get
to give them back we went up to uh
Newfoundland in November December uh
with my daughter who was uh working on a
show up there my wife and I my wife Deb
and I went up to take care of the little
guy who was five months so we literally
did everything from bottle feeding to
diapers to this to naps she hasn't done
in like years yeah right yeah so we had
a great bonding experience with him
which was precious but I've never been
more exhausted in my life
babies are definitely for younger people
uh but he's he's just uh he's a joy we
love him so much oh that's so exciting
for your whole family that's so cool
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]